Once upon a time, there was a
beloved bear named Winnie the
pooh.
Children loved him so much they
introduced him to their own
children.
But then, deep in the woods,
something went very, very
wrong.
And a bloody slasher film was
born.
Brace yourself, here is a clip.
>> Christopher, we need to
leave, now!
>> I really need to find out
what's happening, okay?
♪ ♪ ♪
>> You have.
That's the new movie.
We need the, blood and honey.
I'm choking on.
It joining me now, writer
executive producer, director,
an executive producer, Scott
Jeffrey.
Which one of you is the
deranged sick mind that thought
this was going to be a great
idea?
>> It's both of us.
>> You both liked the idea,
ra'eese, of turning when need
the boot into an homicidal
maniac?
>> Yes, when we saw the rights
which came out in approximately
January 2022, we got really
excited.
We had a glimmer in our eyes.
And we had to given a
[inaudible]
>> I mean it's so scary.
It's so gross.
And so --
I mean, just explain to me your
thought process for a minute
here.
I'll start with theories.
This is a beloved children's
book and so who are you hoping
the audience is?
>> Yes this definitely isn't
for kids it is for adults so
anyone who grew up on we need
the pool when they were younger,
and fast forward now 20 years,
now you have this version.
>> Yes.
>> And Scott, piglet?
You couldn't leave piglet alone?
>> I mean he's up for grabs as
well, and he's been so lovely
and kind for so long, why not
see him a bit arranged as well.
>> Why not ticker?
>> He's not in the public
dominion.
Full >> But you have to gear up
your sleeve, are you going to
do something very bad to take
arson?
>> Reese, what do you reckon?
>> Yes I think it's coming he's
not in the public domain yet
but he will be and are already
planning to have ideas on what
to do with him.
>> Guys it's so creepy and it's
so awful.
Part of it is hilarious because
it is the juxtaposition of we
need the push and the slasher
film.
But part of it is so
disturbing.
I mean did it give you, Rhys
frake-waterfield, any pause, no
pun intended, that you are
going to ruin we need the proof
or the next generation?
>> No.
We [laughter]
That.
How about you Scott?
>> I think that there's been
that version of winning for so
long and now this is a
different version of Winnie,
people just love horror movies
and if you don't like it you
don't need to watch, it there's
no gun to anyone's, head it
doesn't need to exist you if
you don't like or.
But if you do like or it very
much exists.
You are getting his head but
you are doing many things.
Here's one more clip that I
will play for the viewers we
♪ ♪ ♪
>> Why are you doing this, we
used to be friends?
Why are you doing this?
Please!
>> Piglet I'm so sorry I didn't
know any of this would happen,
I thought you'd be okay without
me.
Why are you doing this, we used
to be friends?
Why?
Stop!
>> Scott, it is so creepy and
so just tell us the process of
making it.
I mean were you laughing, where
people freaked out?
What was it like coming up with
the costumes, all of that?
>> When you are on set, Rhys
frake-waterfield is just sat
behind the monitor, giggling
the entire time.
And, Rhys frake-waterfield you
had some crazy ideas with this,
situations in the polls, for
example?
>> Yes, we basically, when we
realized it went into the
public domain into February
2022, we had a partly work for
items studio.
And we both just got really
excited and eager.
We started brainstorming.
And we wanted to make it a bit
like Michael Myers, make it
massive, piglet has a
sledgehammer.
And then they go on a huge
rampage.
>> And so, guys, what else do
you have obviously?
What else is coming into the
public domain that you are
going to completely run for
children, next?
>> Scott's next.
>> Yes, I'm directing Bambi the
reckoning.
And that is shooting at the end
of may.
And Bambi is going to be a
killing machine.
So, yes, you can expect that to
come.
And then very shortly after,
it's called need the puck to.
And it's got five times the
budget, more friends might be
saying hello.
And then we have Peter pan's
neverland nightmare.
But we are just doing things
related to Disney.
We have other things to that
aren't out yet.
>> Well, you guys are sick and
twisted.
And we thank you for showing
all of that with.
Us really appreciate it.
Rhys frake-waterfield and Scott
Jeffrey, thank you very much.
Let's bring in the panel.
Now again, Natasha as our
resident great school teacher.
Well [laughter]
How disturbing is this?
>> I'm disturbed.
I'm disgusted.
I think we like seeing
characters behaving badly, like
there is something about that
in the culture that would be
entertaining.
I would've liked a comedy.
Give me Winnie the pooh at
mardi gras.
You know, taking shots or
something.
I'm not sure that I like the
slush are part.
My toddler will not be getting
the we need the boost of the
animal if this is going to be
the new face of we need the.
I think I'm just going to
cancel when it approve.
>> Isn't that a bummer?
We need the poop will be run
for future generations.
>> Well, if they watch this
slasher film, which I urge them
not to, I, mean we need the
Putin is sort of --
an anybody who has children
knows what it is, but I am more
disturbed, not about the film,
but about the copyright 95
years.
I, mean it suddenly allows
somebody to hijack Bambi,
hijack tartan.
>> But, it's just designed that
way?
>> Yes, so people are waiting
like vultures for when grade
classics are suddenly public
domain and they grab it.
They do with the music to.
But, you know, there's nothing
to do.
There is no legal recourse.
And, as they said, just don't
watch it.
But I find it a waste of time
but that is just the way I'm
wired.
>> It is pretty arbitrary that
95 years shouldn't be when you
stop having rights over your
own work.
Especially in --
for artist who already have
trouble keeping and making
money on their contact.
It's pretty depressive.
>> First, you are saying it's
kind of awesome.
>> Well, I was thinking that
that didn't count.
>> Well, I was saying as
someone who manages other
literary state management, you
do spend a lot of time trying
to see if you can get any cash
out of the content.
But, in this case, it is
actually hurting the books.
>> Right, because it expires.
>> Right.
Instead of just becoming too
families to say can we use this
and buy it for you.
We understand that.
>> Right, right.
And you cannot imagine the
family is thrilled that they're
making a slasher movie with
this childhood.
>> The most disturbing thing to
me is that he said people who
grew up with this 20 years ago.
That was 50 years ago.
That disturbed me more than
anything else about this.
That was 50 years ago for me.
You could see the generational
difference.
But, again, I think culture
reflects society.
And there's gonna be some
people that loved it.
But, more to what you're saying
about the, work that is more
concern for people.